have you ever been frustrated because
you made a video and you put so much
energy into it but it just didn't get
the views that it deserved i know that i
have and in this video i'm actually
going to be talking about how to revive
dead videos a video that is maybe
plateaued it deserves more views how do
you actually trigger it in the algorithm
and actually revive that video so that
it can start getting views 24 7 365.
we're going to talk about that in this
video and this is actually one of the
most powerful youtube strategies that
nobody is talking about and i've
actually never shared this information
before and here's what we're going to
cover
this is a video that wasn't doing very
well as you can see now it's a year old
and it's got 68 000 views
but in my opinion it deserved a lot more
views than it got and you can actually
see that here that
the typical performance on the channel
is this gray area in youtube analytics
and the video was kind of just doing
average right it was kind of slightly
growing but it was sort of flatlined but
then what happened was there was an
inflection point do you see that there's
a dramatic uptick in views that blue
line starts to go up and then this video
rose above
typical performance so how do you do
that that's what you're going to learn
and
this video is all about how to revive
dead videos and trigger massive views
but if you're new here my name is sean
cannell this is the coffee with kennel
show if you're fired up hit the like
button and uh we're going to get into it
today after about 15 minutes of training
we're then going to cover your questions
and so much more here we go three two
one
[Music]
welcome back to coffee with cannell i'm
sean cannell and let's get into the
content today how do you revive dead
videos and trigger massive views today's
coffee with kennel is brought to you by
win this tech.com if you have not heard
we are giving away a sony zve10 brand
new camera we're giving away a lighting
kit a microphone an sd card a tripod
everything you need to create content
and all you have to do to enter
is go to win this tech dot com and i'll
tell you a little bit more about that
later
but
how do i send significant traffic to a
video that is plateaued you know if you
have a video and let me know in the
comments you actually have a video
you've poured energy into
and you're proud of it but you just feel
like it hasn't gotten the views that it
deserved
if you want to
send views
aka traffic to an older video how could
you do that well you could do a facebook
post that's not gonna work very good
though because on facebook right um
facebook doesn't like youtube that's why
when you post a youtube link on facebook
it doesn't get much organic reach at all
because facebook mark zuckerberg doesn't
want anyone to leave the metaverse and
go to the youtube verse right you could
try to post on instagram very difficult
to move people from a social media
platform to another social media
platform what are you gonna do link in
the bio maybe the clickable link in your
stories and sure one to two percent if
you're an absolute social media legend
maybe five percent is gonna go over to
youtube but it's not very effective now
you could send a tweet out not a bad
idea but it's probably not gonna
actually revive your video you could do
a collab this would be amazing what if
you could collab with a big youtuber in
your space that has a similar niche and
they could actually at the end
link to one of your videos that would be
pretty powerful but
how do you get a collab what if you
don't know anyone that's very difficult
it takes coordination you got to deal
with somebody else's schedule somebody
else's personality and then one of the
best things you could do is you could do
a youtube community tab post because at
least it's on the youtube community tab
whether you do your own community tab or
actually if you got a shout out on
somebody else's community tab but the
problem is none of these methods are
really going to revive your dead video
and so this is the most powerful way
we've discovered at think media and i
was telling you this story about this
video that wasn't doing very well and
here's how we revived it here's the
strategy send traffic
aka views to your dead video with a new
video and i'm going to show you how so i
created a new video on a popular topic
in my niche you know i'm on a mission to
help 10 000 purpose-driven people create
a full-time living doing what they love
with youtube and online video
while making a difference in the world
and so one of the biggest questions that
people growing a youtube channel want to
know is how to get views on
youtube
and so
the question you should ask is what is a
popular topic in your niche
a wider reaching topic does it have
wide appeal more mass appeal not that
you want to step outside of videos that
will attract your ideal audience but
does the video have more of a wider
appeal and then i said how can i make
this video really pop what does that
mean how can i spend more time preparing
how can i spend more time editing how
can i be more intentional with my title
and my thumbnail and sure enough this
video performed incredibly well so step
one is create a new banger video right
you just want to do your best there's
really nothing to lose here because
anytime you create a great video and put
extra energy into it you're giving that
video the best chance of succeeding on
its own merits but here's the key
secondly you want to weave in a call to
action to the quote unquote dead
video and so in this video about how to
get views i mentioned a bunch of tips
and one of the tips that i mentioned was
you could add music to your videos by
adding music it creates emotion it
creates a feeling it creates energy so
consider adding music to one of your
videos it was actually one of the seven
tips i shared in this video and if you
actually i highly recommend researching
some of these videos because you can see
exactly what i said and exactly how the
video was edited we'll summarize the
references in the youtube description
below as well as other show notes so
take advantage of those but
ultimately uh you can see here part way
into the video i'm now sharing the fifth
tip and i'm mentioning music and
the final step is you want to link to
the dead video with end cards and so as
i'm sharing music i say and listen um
you know
one of the big mistakes you can make
with music is you use music that has is
copy written it's going to get your
video flagged you're going to lose
demonetization and so actually
if you want to learn where to get
royalty-free music that's not going to
give you copyright strikes we have a
video on that click or tap the screen to
watch it and then we utilize the end
card to send traffic to the video but
you might be asking
but sean all good in theory how do you
know this works how can you prove this
works i'm glad you asked i'm gonna show
you and so
to recap the steps though step one is
what is one of your best older videos
that has plateaued or has stopped
getting views here's the key you're not
just trying to send traffic to like an
older video that maybe it's not your
best doesn't deserve being promoted as
much it's like i mean you know you're
not just because
think about your a new person watching
your channel
you want to give them that best first
impression think about you find somebody
that you want to go on a date with you
want to make that first date as special
as possible but you also want to make
the second date as special as possible
so think about they're watching whatever
new banger video that you put out what's
the second date what's the next video
that they should watch so what's one of
your best older videos that has
plateaued or stopped getting views
then step two what is a new video idea
related here's a huge key
related to your older video that would
be natural for the viewer to watch next
you don't want to just necessarily take
a a hard pivot away from
the topic of the video they just watched
the key being that uh what would be a
logical video for them to watch next so
in my video if you just learned about
how to get views and one of those tips
is music but hey don't make the mistake
of using copy written music or music
that's going to get your channel flagged
or your video flagged and if you need
help with that i've got a video on it
and so i've done a couple things there
it is a logical next video to watch and
i've actually woven in reasoning to
watch it and actually have woven in some
danger if you don't actually heed the
information behind door number two of
this next video you could be in trouble
and your channel could get flagged so
there's a lot happening in terms of
stacking
the
journey of the viewer
to naturally want to watch this video
next so here's two strategies for
reviving dead videos and honestly if
you've already found this video valuable
and you're getting some creative ideas
it would mean the world to me if you hit
the like button and even consider
sharing this video with somebody that
maybe would want to learn some of this
information
so two strategies for reviving dead
video strategy one jump on an industry
related trend and or react to a relevant
article
in your industry
that will be a current
revival
of what it is you talk about on your
channel
let me give you let me demonstrate so
nolan mol on the think media team
made a new banger video as we discussed
by discovering an article about how
netflix does their thumbnails
and about how netflix
actually reveals the secret to getting
more views they've discovered
best practices
of what thumbnails on netflix get the
most clicks and there's some shocking
revelations like how many elements
should be in each thumbnail
like what the color scheme should be of
the thumbnail what they've learned from
thumbnails that did terrible and didn't
send as much traffic to the content on
netflix and others that did better
so nolan discovered this article that
summarized this information and he also
discovered like a reddit thread and a
twitter conversation so i'm asking you
the strategy is maybe there's something
you can jump on something trend related
something influential netflix is very
influential we're here to help you learn
how to do youtube content and so
learning from netflix's thumbnail
strategy is very relevant to helping you
with your thumbnail strategy and i
highly recommend checking out this video
but here's the key there was an older
video that nolan did all about titles it
was really valuable it was really great
but it wasn't doing as well as it should
we like man more people need to know
about this and again you might have that
emotion
man i've this is a great video i want to
get this information to people's hands
this is the point of reviving dead
videos this is the point of making new
content that strategically points to
older content so at the end of this
netflix video nolan says
after you catch someone's attention with
the thumbnail which was the core content
taught
revealed from netflix's strategy the
next thing you need to master is the
title and as you can see in the
screenshot
there is a end card you're going to be
using youtube end cards
that pops on screen that shows up during
the last 20 seconds of your video
and nolan is like hey go watch that
video now now what's crazy
is this newer video already has done
better it's done superior and it has
more views
than this older video
but because of
thinking ahead and planning ahead and
planning out content rather than just
letting that own that video do well but
not point anywhere else
how
smart and thankful are we at think media
that there was foresight to weave in a
transition at the end of that video
to reactivate to revive an older video
in the library pretty cool right and so
what is the next
thing they should watch or the next
thing they would like or the next
video in the series or the next
video they should watch that's what you
want to actually weave into your content
this honestly doesn't really work
if you do it as an afterthought like oh
crap my video's already shot it's
already done
hmm how can i end it a lot of people put
end cards on the end of their videos but
they are not
experiencing their maximum potential
because they're not weaving a transition
into the content itself into the verbal
call to action in the video itself but
sean does it work well um you can see
here now that this video
was doing decent and it was kind of
plateaued slightly growing but then
there's an inflection point and what do
you think happened there
that is the moment by the way at day 80
this video was 80 days old now
that that new video came out and gave a
very
strategic and integrated call to action
using youtube end cards at the end to
this old video about
titles remember it was a new video about
thumbnails that was taught off a
trending article from netflix
linking to an older video in the library
teaching on titles from a time before
crazy moment right you could see that
verifiable result and here's what we've
learned
this has the potential for the video to
be truly
revived but also the result is
activating the result is activating end
screens and multiple other traffic
sources
driving views to your video
so so this video on titles was being
viewed in youtube search but notice
browse features 24 suggested videos 10
and end screens so it's getting 10
of its 516 views
every
two days
from
the end screen that now gives a call to
action to this video what am i saying
that sometimes
not only will you get views directly
from end screens but it actually truly
has the potential to revive the video
because now
someone
this is deep someone who
actually never saw that video but
they're the person who should see that
video would love that video and would
watch the entire thing
is intrigued by the new piece of content
and when you point them to that other
piece of content they love it they watch
the entire thing they watch a large
portion of it average view duration
then youtube goes wow this video
is getting some watch time it's getting
some average view duration and people
like this person like this video so it
activates the other traffic sources
so end screens becomes the best way to
start sending some initial traffic but
as demonstrated here
you can now see other traffic sources
all being lit on fire
and if you go back to the actual curve
this view growth line is not related to
just
end screen views
end screen views is only
50
every two days that's 10 percent of of a
516 but it's getting a lot more views
than that so the whole video was being
revived
because though of that moment of
activation from a new banger sending
traffic to this other video so the
result
in act
is that you activate end screens and you
activate multiple other traffic sources
driving views to the video pretty
powerful
and you can see here
that
this very video example
performed at a two percent higher
click-through rate than the channel
average so what does that mean it means
that if you just use end screens you
should
and in general if you just throw an end
screen out and there isn't necessarily
like a strategic call to action to it
we get like 3.7
of people that cn screens click on them
this one did
hundreds of percent better
mathematically like by a factor of
almost almost double better in terms of
end screen performance why because it
was so it was woven in so strategically
because the new banger video
thoughtfully pointed to the other so
this video got a 5.3 click click-through
rate this one got you know channel
average was 3.7 here's strategy number
two make a new video
about one piece of a larger video
so let's say you've made a
longer video that covers a lot of things
you could consider
breaking out just a piece of that or
talking at think media we say teach a
piece just covering like one piece of
that
and that new video
can activate and revive the older dead
video right
and so here's the example
i made a video called cool tech under 30
dollars it was about cool office
accessories and desk accessories under
50
now this new video was a true banger on
its own merits browse feature 72 in
traffic you can see that blue line 224
000 views since the videos come out in
the last 55 days
uh watch times crushing 2 000 new
subscribers new great video and you
might be thinking well what if i make a
new video and it just doesn't do very
well no big deal
try again
you can do this as many times as you
want you can do new content that
continues to point to an older video in
your library that people really need to
see or that has strategic use in your
business and so this new video did very
well
and this video though is
only about
five items that are under fifty dollars
in regards to my entire compared to my
entire office setup
at the end of the video and you can see
i'm still on screen here i'm like so hey
those are five cool office accessories
under fifty dollars but listen like if
you actually have questions about other
things or you're curious about the
entire office setup i did a video about
that
so what i did right was i made a new
video about just one piece
of the larger video
here's what's kind of shocking
is there is a lot of strategy and of
course i hope you learn so much stuff at
think media and from our content and and
i hope you've you know seen like our
thinkmediasale.com and we have a lot of
resources that are going to help you
strategically but in addition to quote
unquote doing everything right
youtube still is kind of a matter we
it's like a matter of odds it's a matter
of uh of just how many out at bats like
every 10 videos you throw out this is
kind of even my philosophy like if i
post 10 videos i hope three to five of
them
like have a long lifespan and do great
and i'm happy with those odds like i'm
just committed to posting quality videos
of course every time i want to go viral
every time i want things but it's also
just the discipline
it's the discipline of being committed
to creating content committed to being
consistent to committing to trying to
make each video better but never getting
and here's the key never getting too
emotionally tied up with one video
i did do as good as i thought it did on
to the next one and i can use the next
one to point to the one that i really
wish people saw right always thinking
like man the more videos you post on
youtube the higher your chances of
having more breakout videos on youtube
the more videos you post on youtube that
are strategic the higher your chances of
having more videos growing
why is this so significant
is because
the hero video
the complete office tour
right the full length video
didn't do nearly as good as the video
about five office accessories
but what's cool
is the the cool home office desk
accessories under fifty dollars links
to the full length video
so they are cross promoting each other
do you see how powerful this is and so
they're they're they're they're
promoting each other and then watch
here's the full length video which was
doing well on its own
browse feature is pretty good 46 percent
but friend the end screen
is 20
of end screen views so out of 705 views
every two days that's 141 views driven
by end screens from the other
video crazy right
and so
sometimes even the best quote unquote
video in a series of videos you make
might not be the most popular
what i mean to say in all of this last
rant was like
that you don't always know you can't
always you can't necessarily predict
viral you don't know which video is
going to do better than the other videos
so how do you ensure youtube success you
don't just post one video and pray
you post 10 videos and pray you post 10
videos and then pray and then realize
whoa three of them did pretty good
four did all right two kind of did bad
people really need to see those and then
you maybe use the strategy to cross
promote all of them strategically using
youtube tools like end cards um as we've
described and here's kind of what's cool
to check this out in your youtube
analytics is you can go this is our
think media analytics you could go to
engagement and you can actually see
on the right side of the screen here it
says top end screens in the last 28 days
and it actually tells you that cool home
office accessory uh video that i was
just describing that is actually driven
4109 views that netflix video that has
driven 3293
clicks
so
3293 people clicked to go watch the
title video next so you can actually
verify
this strategy working
in your youtube analytics so let me ask
you a question
what is a video in your library
that you think deserves more views
and if you're not sure about that i
would love to hear from you in the
comments what youtube questions do you
have do you enjoy trainings like this
what was your aha moment from this
training let me know in the comments
what's a youtube question you have
um that you would like to see covered in
the future maybe it's about other
youtube features uh please let me know
would love to help and super pumped
because uh today's video besides
windowstech.com if you have not heard
for a limited time we're doing a holiday
sale at thinkmediasale.com
and so if you love this kind of content
and you're serious about growing your
youtube channel in 2022 and you want to
geek out on all things
titles thumbnails scripts
and our 7c system for youtube success
our holiday sale includes our youtube
made simple course our youtube starter
kit and our youtube strategy workshop
which is a three different things all in
one bundle and then discounted over 80
percent
so if you have not seen this i want to
make sure you just know about this sale
so you don't miss out before the price
goes up
thinkmediasale.com we're running it just
through the holidays
link in the description down below
if you're serious about youtube you're
going to be blown away this is 10 times
more valuable than the price you're
paying and you're going to love the
content inside of this and it's going to
help you go further faster so
thinkmediasale.com and um and cough it's
coffee with kennel today so if you've
got a question about youtube throw up
five question marks before and after
your question
and um i'll be back with you
for
the q a did you see thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle
get over 1 900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
welcome back to coffee with kennel uh
i'm here for your q a we got questions
coming in and let me know though where
are you watching from in the world today
a teaspoon miner it's good to see you
appreciate the love this is coffee with
kennel but i'm out here with the
splendrift sparkling water with real
squeezed fruit in it what are you
sipping on uh today
uh got to i'm doing a shoot over at
anderson studios here in just a bit
think media team is coming into vegas
for our
annual all-team leadership retreat super
fired up about that what's happening in
your life my son's 14 months old and he
just stuck his little cheeto finger
inside of my canon r6 mirrorless camera
jacked the shutter thing up and then
swiped his finger across the sensor it's
probably destroyed
parenting
parenthood
fatherhood
what a blessing and so i packed up that
camera yesterday and shipped that into
uh canon service department any parents
in the house um feeling feeling
the emotions
of uh of anything like that happen and
success is the goal it's gonna see a
fourth cup of coffee today perry picture
is always coffee you know it um
watching from florida good to see you
homestead the uk in the house thanks for
being here what time is it where you're
at vancouver island good to see ya my
wife and i you know we grew up in
seattle and we went to vancouver island
on a trip once so we drove up to uh
vancouver bc oh no no uh maybe it wasn't
vancouver island what's that other
island
langley
something like that where you go up you
take a ferry backwards towards it that's
a cool spot northeast ohio in the place
turkey in the house good to see you i
see a lot of questions coming in i want
to oh i got to shout out the green juice
though i just had some green juice and i
had my
my uh like my my shot
um
uh jack daniels just kidding you know
like like 8 a.m i had my uh
ginger shot what do you call them like
emo
ginger g shot
all right listen let's answer some
questions in here and smash like if
you're having
a great day i want to get to a question
that i saw
that was really powerful
and here it is
architectural sheet metal 101 asks
how do we use the data from our audience
retention graph to make
better
videos well there's a couple things to
consider when it comes to this question
and using
your audience retention graph i actually
think that before you get to the graph
i like to go to the first 30 seconds i
think what youtube has shown us most
recently
is they've shown us that
in terms of key moments from audience
retention they are obsessed with the
first 30 seconds
one of the ways you should think about
your youtube videos is like a journey we
teach it as the perfect video recipe it
starts with
the um hook no it starts with the big
idea then it goes into the hook then it
goes to the content and then it goes to
transitioning to another video
and so
when you think about youtube
you don't want to i like to think about
it in steps it's like first how do i get
someone to stop scrolling on on youtube
with the thumbnail second how do i
further pique their interest with the
title
third
if they now love the thumbnail or at
least they're interested and the title
intrigues them now they've clicked the
video so what do they see in the first
second what do they see in the second
second
so it really doesn't matter if i hide a
pot of gold at minute seven in the video
if they're still not watching after the
first 30 seconds and this is verified by
youtube itself it says key moments of
audience retention
um
above typical intros these are people
that are still watching at 30 seconds so
then you start thinking about what
happened in these videos and so you can
study here
what happened during the first 30
seconds of these of these videos
what was said what's maybe seen on
screen that grip people's attention
eight out of ten people
are still watching this top video during
the first 80 seconds eight out of ten
people and then
you know we could go down to the bottom
and see that
that
five out of ten people are still
watching this uh video after the first
30 seconds and we can think about all of
those types of things right
and so
ultimately um i think about that first
and then i think about the rest of it
and what what
youtube shows us on the right side here
let's hit it from a different side let's
maybe head over to our top performing
videos
and study the accessories one we'll go
to cool home office accessories
notice that there is the average this is
typical retention on our channel
so our typical retention on think media
is the gray
uh you know
bar gray range gray range of viewership
so the blue is outperforming
that uh typical retention it's above
typical retention
if the biggest things you can do to
study is you say what happens when it
drops why did this drop so significantly
right here
so you know what's interesting is at
this moment i'm saying
i'm giving a call to action i'm saying
if you're getting creative ideas can you
hit the like button and there's some
loss there's either some finger
scripting there's either a little
intentional scrolling or there's a
reminder at that moment by asking for
the like
audience retention dipped
um and so you'd be saying where what are
the dips and you'd also be asking
what are actually the higher points and
in some cases
this is because of time codes you can
see that uh the chapters people skip to
that chapter so that's why that peaks
but if it's not based on a actual
chapter
it could be something cool on camp this
is showing that b-roll matters this is
showing that
um ooh
command strips what are those and i
don't know if you're like me sometimes
while the video is playing you hover
over it to see is there anything juicy
coming up is there any
images is there anything beyond this
person just being a talking head
and so all of those nuances um
can just help you
refine uh your next video and and then
it's a trade-off so
i'm thinking about it as we're talking
about here here on coffee with piano i'm
like man
is it worth it doing that verbal call to
action to get the like is it worth it to
um
could we do that in a less invasive way
in fact you know i was just talking to
omar about a video and
one i forgot to say hey hit the like
button earlier on but then i actually
maybe that's an opportunity because i
said hey one of the things we should add
to this video is the little pop-up
graphics
that remind people to like that's less
intrusive it might remind maybe a less
percentage of people to like but it's
not going to interrupt their viewing
experience so while you're in the midst
of content you've seen it this way you
should add editing elements
you know it's like if you're getting
value click like or like a little just
it says like and it goes you know mouse
click click and and that shows up on
screen or subscribe so all these
different things
are what we should be
kind of constantly evaluating because
what gets measured gets improved and you
know the sixth
r in our 7r framework is review like if
you're really serious about
your youtube channel you want to take
time to not just post a bunch of content
but but see what's working what's not
working and then
adapt your strategy
accordingly
that was a lot um cheers to to that are
you finding this uh
insightful
um i hope so and uh thanks for being
here today on coffee with kennel if
you're over on facebook i just want to
say i appreciate you
and it would mean the world to me if you
um hit like on the on the post and tag
somebody in the facebook comments or
just click the facebook share button
because i definitely want to get the
word out about uh this conversation and
anybody that needs help with youtube
should join us
while we're uh sipping our drinks today
together
um success is the goal asks when
starting a second channel to split out
the non-niche earlier content after a
pivot are there any issues with
reposting the video
so you start a second channel
because you want to make sure you niche
down and you want to post
a video from the first channel on the
second channel are there any issues
it's not youtube's favorite thing to
post an absolute duplicate video in any
case
because it's on a separate channel they
probably wouldn't notice
in my experience if i've re-uploaded the
same video by accident i never really
wanted to post the exact same video
meaning it's exactly five minutes it
exactly has a certain amount of content
you upload it twice youtube often says
duplicate and they just reject it
um but if you upload it on a second
channel you shouldn't really have an
issue
so that is thing one thing too is
the way we do it is we do remix the
content a little bit
um we kind of repackage it a little bit
you know oftentimes what we'll do from a
full length coffee with candle episode
like this if there's a good q a question
that clip is cut out and the minimal
amount of remixing not that you have to
take it this far but it's worth
considering you've made it new
if let's say that original video was a
25 minute live stream you know like can
i just download it and upload it on my
new channel well you could probably trim
forty percent of that thing trim out the
fluff jump cut it a little bit
or or very minimally because
take it back to uploading a duplicate
video on your channel
if there's a five minute video
you download it or go to your editing
software and you make it four minutes
and 55 seconds it's already different
youtube won't think it's duplicate it's
different even if you just cut the end
off cut the thing off change the deal
cut out that boring part and that would
be kind of worth doing as well so uh you
should be good to go but um take it as
an opportunity if you're quote unquote
re-uploading it to maybe improve it even
slightly and it could do better in its
next location
uh foolish investor appreciate the super
chat thank you so much
um i had a very successful video
at 18 000 views versus 4 000 typically
but it was off topic and since then
my new topic uploads have tanked did i
mess with the algorithm
that's a uh that is a good question
and that is the
that is the crazy emotional
rollercoaster that is youtube youtube
plays on our emotions because we can
want to go after views which is not a
bad thing to go after
but
we also
not all these are the same and if
they're the wrong views or they're
attracting the wrong audience they might
give us a short term dopamine hip hit
but long term
they may not be what's best for our
channel
and so um
okay that makes sense you know squid
game is what i think you're replying to
went well
squid game token explained and
i do think that maybe that applies to me
it seems like that could apply to still
investing
um it looks like you have a couple other
videos doing great though and then
i would just challenge based on what i'm
seeing here
that your new uploads have quote unquote
tanked
i think there's a difference between
um you know like
causation um and correlation
and
that's it's because youtube messes with
our brain there's
really like kind of cool but very toxic
serotonin
dopamine
like releases that happen when you crush
it on youtube that lead to peaks that
make your brain cloudy and then you're
like emotional the next day and you're
like what the heck happened like i got
13. i got 14 000 views but like but now
i'm only getting 500
453 and here's the problem
like every single one of these videos
has different topics like
maybe people they just don't care about
the docusign stock they care more this
was a better title there's and and
legitimately there's there's like 100
factors
the new video topic the new video title
the time of day
you you take it you're like the
algorithm is broken you didn't realize
that that was like a holiday for a huge
segment of your audience because maybe
people of a certain faith watched your
channel and that and you know what i
mean like they take that day off and you
were like it's a statement of of my
value as a human this is things i go
through you know what i mean and so
i think it's good that you're observing
it all
i think that if it is that squid game
video of course it's going to
potentially do disproportionately well
but i but i don't see any problem with
it i think you're over thinking of
thinking it uh you did not mess with the
algorithm
um
and
youtube does judge each video on its own
merits
so sometimes we we i want to encourage
you and everybody watching don't be too
afraid
that like your next upload has the
potential to tank your channel and your
career
like if you have a bad video
what happens is
you know you get your score last out of
10 it's 10 out of 10 which is not a good
thing for anybody that knows youtube
analytics you want one out of 10 right
it's 10 out of 10.
you go if you see that
here's the truth
one of your videos will always have to
be 10 out of 10. like i guess on the
flip side if they were always 1 out of
10 it means you'd be on this endless
winning streak
like eventually you're gonna have a 10
out of 10. like that's okay it's all
right that some of your videos won't do
as well
and if they don't do very well most
share subscribers won't even see them
youtube will kind of kill it but your
next at-bat is your next upload great
title great topic great thumbnail
and
go at it again
you did not kill the algorithm
you're all good i appreciate you
um
hey thanks for keeping the super chats
rolling in i like it uh thank you
foolish investor so um in the it was a
video on how much money mr beast made
which i deleted
okay well
um okay and i get it and it wasn't maybe
investing it was just
it makes sense
and i'm glad you brought this up like
these are tensions to be managed i don't
think they are black and white answers
their tensions to be managed
if you have a video that drops on it
drops jumps on a trend like mr beast you
might attract a lot of an audience
you might but you might attract the
wrong audience maybe you tr attract you
wanna you wanna reach let's just play
out a scenario you wanna reach gen x and
baby boomers who really can invest
because eventually
even the cpms and who you talk to and
how you help people i'm not saying
that's what your channel is doing but
that is the goal of a channel meanwhile
you see that oh it's i can get a lot
more views if i talk about mr beast okay
so then you have a video and it what it
does is it creates delusion because then
you go oh my gosh this video did amazing
well sure but
the demographic watching it is not the
demographic you're ultimately trying to
reach
so a lot of times if you are a youtube
entrepreneur and you're coming at it
with a business-minded approach and
really thinking about the legacy and the
audience
and the vision of the channel you want
to build
deleting a video that's doing well could
be the most strategic thing you possibly
could do so foolish investor i'm glad
you shared this because this is learning
for all of us here at coffee with kennel
um
but
and and i would say let's summarize
i think that um we just talked about
this as kind of a new concept at think
media
uh i was talking about our producer tony
about
being on brand have you ever have you
heard anybody ever say that like is that
on brand for us
and i want you to picture a dart board
okay so there's a dart board
and
and perfectly on brand for your channel
would be a bullseye
and
on brand but just barely would be
the dart is right on the edge of that
dartboard it almost it almost hit the
wall it almost put a hole in the wall
you know
and if you then think about if it's
outside of the entire target it's
off-brand
so
you know five things
investors can learn
from mr beast
might
dabble into different audience demos but
could be on brand flipside is
literally just how much
you know
mr beast made which lots of channels do
just youtuber kind of about youtubers
about famous youtuber videos which is a
pretty powerful niche um but you're like
it's off brand then you make that hard
decision as you did to delete the video
or to to for some of us watching to not
create the video
i want to pass the question off to you
coffee with kennel
have
you
is there videos on your channel that are
off brand
have you been confused about your brand
where you're like and i think what i
said with tony was like yeah we should
make this video
but it's right on the fringe like it's
on brand for us but like we should not
get distracted those should not be our
next 10 videos once a year we should
maybe make that video it fits in the
think media world but like just barely
let's try to stay as close to bullseye
because the closer you stay to the core
promise the core vision the core
viewer
the the core promise um that your
channel has made
then really the better for it because
your
uh
people expect something from you you've
made a promise to people and you're
delivering on that promise and you're
building up a clear focused audience of
people interested in that particular
type of content smash like if you're
having fun and getting value
today uh good to see you dr andrea i
really appreciate you
and uh it's been awesome to see how much
success you're having on youtube and so
grateful you're a part of uh vra
uh laura good to see you
um
and let's see here foolish investor yeah
i decided to kill it off asap because it
wasn't growing as fast great idea though
for anyone in that niche love it i
appreciate it
um
have you entered
winthistek.com as we get ready for our
next question
there is let me show you some cool
things friends we are giving away a
complete youtube studio it is open
internationally
win this tech.com link in the
description down below if you haven't
entered
when you go there what you're going
gonna see is there's multiple ways to
enter so you log in with your email or
like facebook connect or twitter or
whatever
and then there's different things you
can do you can get daily bonus entries
you can jump on our text message list
and all these things are to add value
like i realize
you know this is helping us grow some of
our social medias but i really want to
invite you to be a part of those things
we're dropping info and extra resources
on twitter
uh over on my instagram sean cannell you
know
i'm sharing youtube tips you'll get a
little behind the scenes
um
you know i share my vision my values a
lot of cool stuff it'd be a great place
to connect active in my dms active in my
comments so anyways that's the
uh it's at windistech.com
and then on this page you can also just
see a little bit about the uh the think
team and some of the stuff that we're up
to but definitely enter the giveaway
there's 12 days left at the time of
being live on this coffee with kennel
you've got 12 days and then the winner
will be announced we're going to
announce the winner on our main channel
on think media um
heather's going to go live
announce the winner it's selected
randomly we use the software it's all
legit it's all transparent it's called
gleam i o
and so uh super fair
so
win
this
tech
dot
com
friendly pharmacy thanks for being here
today i started my channel by accident
during
uh co
dot
vid
uh and now i'm trying to transition the
audience it's challenging why are you
okay
so you're just trying to pivot brands
trying to pivot um
audiences yep it can be it could be hard
just go for it though just just go for
it
the get super clear about your vision
super clear about what you want where
you want to go and then go for it a lot
of self-doubt crap creeps in
um but some people are like you know
what i'm really passionate about is like
airbnbs and house hacking but i have
this you know i already have some
momentum talking about um diy stuff it's
like but if you know this but are you
certain that you're like in love and
that you really want to go deep on
airbnbs and house hiking i am certain
then just go
like one of the best ways to
to
uh pivot and create momentum
literally like momentum is like a train
if it's going one way you have a little
bit of momentum on your current channel
hitch
the only way to get it going the other
direction is not like well let me just
kind of lightly hit the brakes it's like
slam the brakes
start getting the other way it's going
to be hard but exert as much energy as
you can to start getting the train going
the other direction you got people in
the furnace shoveling coal in the engine
room you got the snow piercer engine
eternal trying to get the train
trying to go the other direction anybody
get the snow piercer reference like a
and just go for it like if you're clear
and convicted that you should be going
in this direction and this is what your
future is and this is what you want to
be known for and this is what your brand
is
the future's forward it's time to go
well we're getting negative comments
because somebody was like oh i liked it
better when you were but you know that
sorry susan like i appreciate you but
like i know i'm supposed to go this new
direction your life cannot be fully
based around serving susan you know
that's one person
you care about susan you love susan but
you know you're going towards airbnb and
diy so you gotta go susan you're either
on the train or not cause i'm going
snowpuser has left the station
okay i don't
i don't know why i got so triggered like
are we just
uh that was crazy um okay
tutorials mag when can you say that your
channel is
working or not
is it when you reach 30 to 40 videos and
you don't see much too much traction
so i'm going to answer this question by
pointing you to
a think media podcast episode we'll drop
it in the comments
and uh we'll make sure it's in the
youtube description if you're catching
this on the replay the episode is called
how to know when to quit
so it's it's it's a longer conversation
you can see this is a 37-minute
conversation because i'm going to give
you frameworks it's not a black or white
answer sometimes you need to quit
sometimes you need to stick sometimes
you need to pivot and i believe by the
end of that think media podcast episode
you'll have
clarity
check it out
if you want to rebrand your channel
is it better to delete all the other
videos and leave old ones
or add new videos
it is probably good to make the videos
unlisted
um i don't like deleting videos you can
make them private because maybe someday
you want to like show your kids how
funny your old videos were that's kind
of my take
the key with the videos is if they are
still causing growth they could be
causing the wrong growth so
if you go over to
my channel think media
these first few videos
are not they're they're actually not
off-brand but there's definitely some
off-brand videos on here there's some
like weird interviews and like some
different things that i did but here's
the key
this stuff is getting
none if like one view this is this this
stuff is getting no views unless they're
nostalgic views like people are like i
wonder i want to go like spy on sean's
older videos
um and so they're not being recommended
they're not being suggested they're not
being so i do not see them as a
vulnerability and i personally has left
them up because i think they show the
journey and i think that one of the most
powerful things for you and for me is
our story is our progression you know
people can't relate to your success
unless they've seen your struggle this
is not just i snapped my fingers and all
of a sudden there was a gold play button
beyond my shoulder
this was grind pain
emotions
frustration
fatigue
it's been
it's been 10 years since i started think
media it's been 11 years since i started
think media so anyways i like showing
the journey
however if i had like some
fringe garden video you know where i was
like
you might not have known that i'm really
into tulips but like here's how i've
made my tulips so colorful you know and
all of a sudden that video is like still
going viral and a lot of times that'll
happen to us like
friend do you have a video in your
library if you're watching this that
you're like yeah just keeps getting
views it's like that one time we went to
disneyland and we like showed off that
ride my channel is about cars but like i
went on that family trip
that video can be a vulnerability to you
because it's attracting the wrong
subscribers and people are constantly
subscribing for like disneyland tours
when you're trying to talk about
renovating jeep engines and you got all
these you know you have the wrong
audience subscribing it is harming your
growth and so
um
i don't think you necessarily need to
delete the videos consider making them
unlisted or private
if they're still growing your channel
and then i'd even say more than that
there is some wisdom to
bring like
an actual brand experience
like i got a lot of videos on my shelf i
do think
producer tony we could potentially
you know they're
i i i'm so attached maybe you are too
i'm emotionally attached to every good
video every bad video it's like i love
them all give me all the videos
you know like it's just they're all part
of the story like that little oh that
one was kind of
well that one's a little rough around
the edges
it has a little more character it's cute
because of how
ugly it is you know and so like you got
all these different videos in your
library but i do think there's something
about
leading with the best of the best final
tip i'll give practically is consider
optimizing your homepage you know a lot
of people aren't going to actually
explore your entire life library they're
going to explore your homepage you know
our director of our video ranking
academy program is uh like literally at
the highest level of executing the think
media methodology
how we think about architecting videos
implementing our 7r system
all that kind of stuff and so uh
he in the future
i wanted to teach on this in depth um
and i think nolan might be teaching on
it as well but eventually how you
organize your homepage
into different categories into different
playlists i think also speaks to um the
most the most forefront-facing brand
almost nobody is seeing my really old
videos what they're seeing is what's
being recommended to them and what
they're seeing is like oh i'm here now
let me go to your homepage aka your
webpage your youtube channel homepage is
basically your youtube website
is your website optimized what is the
viewer experience on your youtube
website
does your is it clear
is it fun
is it
accurate
does it represent your brand your brand
values and how you help people the most
think about evolving your youtube
channel page
six shop
super chat i appreciate it thank you how
do you decide what to make videos about
just focused on shorts
now
well that's a great question um
the creator who understands the viewer
best wins
so
asking just what to make videos about in
isolation is maybe not the fully best
question
the best question is who am i making
videos for
to the degree you understand
who you're making videos for
becomes a domino that kicks over the
question of what video
should i make next
what video would be best
or get the most views or perform the
best when i know who i'm making videos
for
and so this is why we ask you to define
who is your youtube channel for and what
problem does it solve
and even if you're just making shorts
you're like what's not like an education
channel well it's entertainment
so what is
if you understand that i'm really trying
to reach
gen z or jen alpha is jen alpha even
watching content sean bradley my son um
he is he he's
he can grab my phone and like
edit a video in imovie it's it's like
crazy how into it he's 14 months old and
he's like swept swoop
you know grabs it like unlocks it or
actually enters the password so many
times that it's like it's gonna take
five minutes to tell your phone
anyways um
what is the psychology
lang communication style humor of the
person you're trying to reach that's
going to inform the content you want to
create i would say that um if you also
want an accelerant
for getting results with that definitely
check out thinkmediasale.com
you know we have
uh our youtube starter kit included in
the sale
and there's some super cool stuff
inside of that
um including you can see there's the
youtube made simple course our youtube
starter kit our youtube strategy
workshop
and inside of the starter kit we have
the youtube clarity blueprint everything
i just said you might have said like
i don't really know
who it's for i don't know what my brand
is i don't know what my strategy is
i don't know what videos to make i'm not
i need to put all the pieces together
i'm not sure how to do youtube right
how can i
identify my own strengths
all of the above you're going to learn
that step by step in this printable pdf
workbook plus we have title formulas so
you don't have to like become an expert
at writing titles you get to just cop
copy off our cheat sheet for writing
youtube titles that are going to get
clicks
we've got our 51 video ideas to jump
start your channel
and we've got our 51 money making video
ideas if you specifically are looking
for the shortest path to earning revenue
and so think media sale in fact here
check this video out here's the details
did you see
thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
percent off our brand new youtube made
simple course bundle get over 1 900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to think
media
thinkmediasale.com
yeah thinkmediasale.com check it out um
we're gonna land the plane in just a
second here but uh daisy did i get those
super chats did i already answer them
and if i didn't they're no longer up and
so um post them in private chat if any
um
are still to cover because i want to
make sure to honor
those um we're not doing channel reviews
today but we will do it again in the
future we did a while back super fun
with tony and heather and omar um and uh
let me know if you were part of that
here's the details on screen
thinkmediasale.com
um 80 off at think media sale dot
um
and smash like if you've been getting
value today
here we go super chat from
maya
appreciate it can videos go viral
months after being published
great question
the answer is uh is yes absolutely
so i'll just
contextualize and land the plane on a
couple things one uh tony the producer
has a faceless channel i don't have a
lot of time to unpack what that is
but he has a video that was hundreds of
days old maybe you'll tell me in the
chat
um literally hundreds of days old that
was going from flatline to just boom it
just started going viral
and
what we've also uh recently i went to a
conference called vidsummit and learned
from a youtube employee
um tony said it was 504 days old and it
did 150 000 views in three days
um
and so
uh
and
so yes
the youtube employee told us don't
overly judge your your video by the
first day first week or even first month
we have seen um a lot of videos that
think media start taking off at
day 200 day 345.
day
463 it's insane
i think that that's a mindset that
doesn't get talked enough about and
that's also something that is deeply
entrenched in our think media
methodology while a lot of people are
focusing on short-term viral
we are focusing on long-term sustainable
we are focusing on videos that over the
long haul
get disproportionate
views
and
it's a it's a legacy-based lifestyle
based strategy
that can be incredibly uh incredibly
helpful and and let me actually show you
in this first of all this video did
disproportionately well
naturally and it's pretty cool it's
generated 22 000 2.2 million views
and you can see this blue line of how
well it's doing
but it's as cool as that is let's look
at down here
on what
what uh happens on think media and what
youtube calls are quote unquote typical
performance
so because of our and this is not every
channel every channel does not benefit
from this
short term based channels viral based
channels trend based channels
topic based channels
versus search based channels evergreen
channels
shelf life content content that has wide
appeal or or rather long-term appeal
i am going to quote and show you on the
screen in my analytics what the
average performance across all of the
videos we post on think media is
over the long haul here's what it is
the typical performance
one year and 351 days into a video
posted on think media
this is over two years now one year and
360 days
is minimum 35 000 views
so if anyone's like why did your video
only get three thousand views i'm like
just give it two years dog it's gonna
get thirty five thousand i promise i can
promise you i guarantee it'll get thirty
five thousand in two years
the range though is a hundred and sixty
two thousand views
so i i could almost i could sit here and
say yeah i mean every one of our videos
gets like basically a hundred thousand
views approximately
no it doesn't it only has four thousand
views right now
bro
what's go like
do you need were your parents mean to
you like do you need you need a hug like
it's gonna be all right dog like no just
chill like i know it looks like that now
but you gotta see a little bit further
down the road like
give this thing two years
you you're judging the game wrong you
don't know how the game is played
but take a deep breath and maybe really
see what's happening in this youtube
thing
so
this is of course
the methodology we're doing which we
would be want to be convicted on and
believe in but the powerful thing about
this
is that when you approach youtube this
way
think about it you post the video today
but it's still getting views for weeks
months and years to come and two years
later
it's continuing to grow those it's it's
somewhat plateaued but you can see that
there's a slight expansion see how
typical grows
watch that see the typical so there's a
big number you see that big black number
it's hard to see the small one typical
in this period is 23 thousand then by
day forty four hundred eighty uh four
hundred and forty eight but i'll land
the plane saying you asked do videos go
viral and this is a good example notice
this one this video did well for the
first 122 days and then boom it actually
had a whole run at day 122
so um
things to consider all right one other
super chat
uh right under
robert teaches english how can i niche
down
as an esl teacher i feel like i'm
creating so much
so
um
i don't think you need to niche down i
mean maybe the question is how to stand
out and i understand that maybe
let me look at your
i know a couple people who
have that language channels
one of the ways they do things is they
they just crush it they do like one
video one word
maybe you're doing that in fact let me
actually see how many videos you're
posting
um
15 videos uploaded that is a lot it's
okay so every other day 15 000 views
it's cool you got a spike here was that
a short we'll see that was a good spike
of views
and maybe there's a good short a year
ago um
i think
you know one one thing that you've
probably seen other channels do
is
one video one word
and that it might make life easier and
also harder you're like i'm creating so
much what do i do
i don't know you get more hooks in the
ocean
and and what i mean by that is a lot of
esl channels right people want to
pronounce one particular hard word and
sometimes these videos the youtube
shorts actually
so if i'm you as this strategy is coming
to me is what i'm doing right now is i'm
actually going youtube shorts
and or
still vertical videos that are just one
word one answer
um and
instead of making a four minute video or
a 10 minute video i'm gonna make 20
videos
pre-schedule them um potentially
and just let them roll out so you said i
want to create less well i might create
more but i might create it in a more
intelligent way or rather a way that
buys my time back gives me more time and
more margin but i think what will also
happen is there will be more wind in
your sails when money's coming in
when growth is happening and you're in a
competitive niche so don't
don't be surprised
at the how hard this is because it is
hard so i think there's something about
persistence grit and then success leaves
clues i'm sure you've studied studied
esl channels
the charge of the day coffee with cannel
is market research not comparison
because comparison is the thief of joy
not i'm gonna go look at other channels
and and have that talk me into
um sucking or you know who am i my
friend john acuff says don't compare
your beginning to somebody else's middle
don't compare your brand new youtube
channel to somebody else oh they're so
much better than me they've been doing
it for 10 years dude give yourself a
break
and and and check out some other
channels but here's your charge
december
market research
like there's something to be learned
from the channels that are experiencing
growth from the channels that are
getting views from breakout videos from
using tools like that iq trending tab so
if i you know
esl channel this is a way to look you
you should know and you should know who
are the five to ten channels killing it
in your industry that you can learn from
um is esl is this a language channel or
is this counter strike that's an actual
game that's not right
uh it's probably this top video six okay
advanced learning channels
speak with vanessa okay great so if i
find her watch this one quick tip shout
out to our friends at vid iq
you go to this trending tab
and this shows you the videos with
velocity on her channel even if they're
20 days old or three months old or two
years old
so then it's oh a 1.5 hour real english
conversation oh that's a cool idea i
could do that it's two years old it's
still getting 158 views an hour
and i don't i don't need to go deeper i
don't got time to go deeper i got to go
to anderson studios
like
one idea boom good tool good execution
of the tool
what 60 seconds of market research
i'm not saying that video is gonna
change your life but it could and that
is the way you can start seeing
something like oh that's cool let me
experiment with that oh that's cool let
me get out of my box well that's cool
let me actually take a second to look at
what's happening in the market look at
what's happening on youtube study
and not compare and not
have it lead me to discouragement have
it lead me to inspiration happy leave
have it lead me to a couple creative
ideas that i can implement so i can set
up and build momentum going into 2022.
if you've been getting value today smash
like on the video and i do want to uh
you know thank you for being here thank
you kate cat slade for the super chat
appreciate you um check out
links in the description down below and
if you like me
uh want to take the holidays to level up
and learn i've spent five thousand
dollars that's not how much our holiday
bundle is but on learning i just got
an advanced business strategy course uh
on sale it was a thousand dollars for my
pen my friend patrick david and so i
printed out the workbook um i
have purchased about six online courses
um
well some of them are bundles and so i'm
and i've already been learning and and
here's the other thing i've been
investing in myself and actually doing
the work
i've got google docs open i'm taking the
notes i'm screen shotting slides i'm
making my game plan i'm putting notes in
my binder uh my note my journal about
okay here's what i'm learning here's how
how i'm going to apply it here's the
sequence of how i'm going to apply it i
really want to invite you
to if you're serious about youtube in
2022 to not miss the youtube made simple
sale
but to actually go through it
like of course well sean do you just
want to sell me a course
well kinda i mean you know what i mean
like it's like i'm like obviously i want
to sell the course like people are like
get so weird about it
but it's because it'll actually add
value to your life
if you are serious about growing on
youtube
i practice what i preach
i invest in myself print out the
workbook block the time on your schedule
put some actual concentrated learning
time don't just swipe on twitter spaces
and join random rubes rooms about
nothing and just turn off netflix turn
off hulu get into a learning mode get
into a battle station mode get into a
mode where you really think about
putting your game plan together for 2022
get into a mode where you really think
about i'm gonna start taking my youtube
channel seriously i'm gonna really learn
really strategize really take advantage
of these resources and here's the thing
the think media team and i work so hard
to put this course together at 80
percent off
to at the for the price of a pair of
yeezys you can actually like get into
a course that'll change your life
if you're serious and it's not for
everybody and if it's not right for you
i don't i don't want you to have this
but if you are on the fence and you have
been hearing about our think media sale
like take advantage of this thing like
you are going to be blown away and the
cool thing is that there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee so even if you're
like i'm not sure if i'm going to get
value no no sweat like literally test it
out but
with the youtube clarity blueprint alone
try like i stand by this when you take
this course
and you enroll in it and you print out
or just download the pdf and open up
your evernote and your ipad and your
fire tablet
and you start going through the clarity
blueprint you are going to feel this
alone was worth the value
just to get
just the printable workbook and to go
through this and margin the time that
was worth the value but there's so much
more in there in terms of the main
youtube simple course the uh
the title
15 title formulas 21 video ideas so
anyways just want you to know about it
because i don't want you to miss out on
the sale and eventually the price will
go up for this and the bundle will go
away we're including the youtube starter
kit so youtube made
what is even the url exhausted at the
end of coffee with kennel
think
mediasale.com is the url definitely
check that out and thanks again for uh
being here on coffee
with
kennel today i appreciate you smash like
if you got value and i look forward to
seeing you in the next episode peace did
you see
thinkmediasale.com for the holidays
we're giving you 80 percent off our
brand new youtube made simple course
bundle get over 1 900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go